There's a story of mine that I've told
about a million different times,
and it goes a little something like this.
When I was 10, my family and I packed up
our entire lives into large suitcases
and dragged them across the Pacific
to a foreign land called Canada.
I was put in a school where I was
the only Asian kid in my grade,
and I got teased for
my broken English, Asian features
and funny smelling ethnic lunches.
The racism was a real doozy.
But don't feel bad.
Through the magical healing powers
of extracurricular activities
and pure perseverance,
I stand before you today, a new woman:
healthy, healed and extremely employable.
You wouldn't even be able to tell
from just looking at me
that I was once
the weird little immigrant girl
who begged her mom to pack PB&J sandwiches
so she wouldn't have to eat lunch
alone in the bathroom.
This is a story that I’ve told
in academic essays, job interviews
and even in the very application
that got me into this fine university.
It's also a story that,
despite all of its truth,
I've come to hate.
Now this is a story
that I don't have copyright claim over.
It's one that continues
to be regurgitated by immigrant kids
all across the country
to be served on a silver platter
to prestigious universities
who chew these stories
and spit out acceptance letters in return.
The contents of the story may change.
Instead of a difficult
immigration experience,
it might be the death of a loved one,
a chronic illness or a racist encounter.
But what remains constant is the moral:
A bad thing happened to me,
but it made me a good person.
This is part of a larger phenomenon
that I'm here to talk about today.
The overwhelming pressure
being put on high school students
to write about their deepest traumas
in their college applications
with the hopes that they seem resilient
and interesting enough to be given a spot.
I believe that these are
not only bad metrics
by which to evaluate applicants,
but also incredibly harmful
to the storyteller themselves
and risks reinforcing
existing inequities in higher education.
There's also pressure
that's being amplified
by admissions counselors themselves
who play a huge role in influencing
what applicants decide to write about.
Take, for example, this tip
from the MIT admissions blog,
where the author compares two different
introductions for a potential essay.
The first one reads:
"I'm honored to apply
for the Master of Library Science program
at the University of Okoboji.
For as long as I can remember,
I've had a love affair with books.
Since I was 11,
I've wanted to be a librarian."
The second introduction reads:
"When I was 11,
my great aunt Gretchen passed away
and left me something
that changed my life:
a library of about 5000 books.
Some of my best days were spent
arranging and reading her books.
Since then, I've wanted
to become a librarian."
The author notes
that the second introduction
is much more striking
and leaves a much better impression.
Consider another tip
from collegeessayguy.com,
where he advises students
to “get personal.”
He says, "Weirdly,
including painful memories
and what you learned from them
usually helps a personal statement
meet the goals
of a college application essay.
You come off as humble,
accessible, likable and mature.”
Confessions from admissions officers
themselves can also be telling.
Aya Waller-Bey,
a former admissions officer
from Georgetown University,
said in a "Forbes" article that,
"Within months on the job,
I saw how the personal statements
of Black and other
racially minoritized students
differed from those of white applicants.
Black students highlighted resilience
through stories of survival,
while their counterparts
wrote casual essays about service abroad
and sporting championships.
Black students shared their pain,
white students shared their passions.”
Now, lastly, and perhaps
the least reliable source is my own life.
I remember feeling this way
when I was applying to universities.
Like I had no other choice,
no other experiences worthy of mentioning
and no other merit beyond the fact
that I had thrived
despite what I had gone through.
I even remember worrying that my tale
wouldn't be harrowing enough
after hearing from a counselor
that writing about immigration
has become a bit of a cliche
because of how overused it is.
So what’s the universities’
role in all of this
and why are these stories
even harmful to begin with?
Well, I believe that using
your college application essay
to discuss your trauma
actually doesn't help you process it.
And there are a couple
different reasons why.
First, writing about
a difficult experience is,
as you may have guessed, difficult.
Not only do you have to
relive the event itself,
but you also have to actively suppress
any negative emotions
that arise during the process.
That kind of emotional labor
can be taxing for anybody,
but perhaps especially so
for these young applicants
who haven't had enough time on this world
to process the terrible things
that have happened to them.
For that space to be one in which
they're confessing to a faceless stranger
who gets to make
the most consequential decision
of their adolescent life
imposes an incredibly heavy
psychological burden.
I mean, imagine if you walked
into your therapy appointment
and your therapist tells you
that they're not going to respond
to anything you tell them
except with a rejection
or acceptance email sent months later.
And also that whatever you tell them
will determine the trajectory of your
entire academic and professional career.
Hard to imagine that being therapeutic.
Secondly, the trauma essay
makes one assumption
that is extremely problematic.
It's not always the learning opportunity
through which you can gain more confidence
or develop better time management skills.
Sometimes it's just
a sucky thing that really sucks.
And asking students to prove
how they turn their pain into progress
ignores this truth and falls prey
to the toxic positivity narrative
that everything happens for a reason,
ignoring the very valid resentment
and anger that many victims still feel.
Lastly, the things we write
aren't just informed by our experiences,
they shape how we view
those experiences as well.
And if we're writing about our trauma
to prove to an admissions officer
that we are worthy of a decent education,
then it becomes necessary
to sanitize our pain,
to make it marketable and strategic,
to scrub away all the suffering,
so all that's left is what will fit
into the narrow margins
of what is palatable.
And this is what I see
as being the fundamental contradiction
at the heart of the trauma essay.
It seems to give the writer
free reign on vulnerability,
but actually leaves them
very little room to be vulnerable.
Your story has to be just sad enough
that it gains sympathy,
but not so sad that it makes you
seem beyond help.
Just critical enough to inspire change,
but not so much that it actually
criticizes systemic structures.
Just honest enough to seem real,
but not so unfiltered
that it creates discomfort.
The protagonist also overcomes
whatever struggle they're facing
by the end of the 500 word count,
instilling the reader
with a sense of optimism
that despite our deeply unequal society,
it is possible to rise through the ranks
and overcome all the “-isms.”
This, of course, is not the reality
of our world today.
And for me, this looked like settling
for the familiar story
of the stinky lunch,
one that's been told so many times
that it's devoid of any real meaning,
instead of talking
about the ongoing social and political
disenfranchisement of immigrants,
the permanent loss
of cultural identity that I suffered,
or the sense of disbelonging
that still haunts me
every time I make a grammar mistake
or someone mispronounces my name.
These are all struggles
that never really go away,
but are carefully tucked away in my essay
because they don't fit
the linear narrative
that is being constructed.
But how are universities
to blame for all of this?
I mean, they never
explicitly asked students
to trauma-dump in their essays,
and many admissions experts
have actually come out
and discouraged discussing
explicit trauma in essays.
However, I still don't think
that universities are blameless.
The reason why the trauma essay
is so ubiquitous
is because it seems to be working.
Anne Trubek, who helped low-income
high school students at Oberlin College
write their essays,
expresses the ethical dilemma
that she faces.
"By pushing students
to reveal their horror stories,
I risk taking away their dignity,
but by not pushing,
I could be hindering their chances
of getting into their dream school."
Whether trauma essays
and acceptance letters
are actually causally correlated
is impossible to tell from the outside.
So this could all just be
speculation and myth.
But in failing to resolutely clear up
these speculations and myths
about whether trauma essays
are rewarded or discouraged,
universities are indirectly enabling
the rise of the trauma essay
and all of its harmful implications.
So what are they to do about all of this?
Well, first of all, I think that
this is a problem that goes much deeper
than individual universities,
and even perhaps the institution
of higher education itself.
It's rooted in the cultural obsession
with appropriating trauma
and making it consumable,
as well as the systemic tendency
to tokenize oppressed people
and their experiences.
But there are still things
that universities can do
to make things better.
First, they can be more transparent
about their admissions guidelines.
If it's really true that they don't want
to reward trauma storytelling
just for the sake of it,
then they should be more forthcoming
about this expectation.
They could also restructure their prompts
to avoid putting pressure on students
to talk about past hardships
and adversities
and instead refocus prompts
to ask students
about their goals for the future
and their academic interests.
Secondly, admissions counselors
should be trauma-informed
and trained in working with BIPOC folk.
As the unofficial gatekeepers
to the secrets of getting
into your dream college,
they should wield their power responsibly
and not pressure students
to talk about traumatic experiences
that they're not yet ready to talk about.
Lastly -- and this one's for anyone
who's actually applying
to a postsecondary institution
sometime soon --
remember that you are more
than the bad things that happened to you.
I know that when it seems like
every other classmate of yours
is writing an essay that could be adapted
for an HBO original drama,
that you may feel like your experiences
are not worth talking about.
But I promise that they are.
You just have to find
your voice and use it.
Now as much as I don't want to live
that nail-bitingly stressful
time of my life ever again,
I can't help but wonder:
what would I have written about
if I got the chance to apply to UBC again?
This time absent the pressure
to strategically use
my immigrant background
to gain sympathy points.
Maybe I would have written about
how I overcame my fear of public speaking
and became comfortable
with being the loudest voice in the room.
Or I could have written about
watching trashy reality television
is what first sparked my interest
in political science.
Or maybe I still would have written
about my immigrant story
because that was a big part
of my life journey
and still impacts me to this day.
But I would have done it on my own terms.
Instead of being written
as a one-dimensional,
trauma-turned-triumph trauma drama,
I would have been able to tell a story
that actually reflects who I am today
and acknowledge the fact
that my journey is ongoing
and it doesn't begin or end
with my racial identity.
This is the kind of ownership
that I wish for everyone
to one day have over their story.
And now it's up for universities
to decide whether they get to tell it.
Thank you.